Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta.
My name is CZ and I started this series one
year ago when I brought you those first Three
Halloween Horror Stories.
This time I'm back with a scary clown creepypasta,
so whatever you're doing this Halloween, turn
this story on in the background for some extra
chills.
Let's dig right in.
As a kid, I never understood why some of my
classmates were afraid of clowns.
I didn't really find them scary.
Not that I found that funny either.
Most of them just looked kind of goofy and
dumb.
I remember having this exact argument with
my best friend Kevin at the lunch tables in
elementary.
His argument was always that I needed to see
the movie IT in order to understand, but being
in second grade at the time, my parents would
never let me watch it.
I actually remember on Halloween, some of
the older kids in the neighborhood dressed
up as clowns and went around scaring trick-or-treaters.
Maybe I just had thick skin, but I remember
one of them chasing our entire friend group
away and me being left on the sidewalk laughing
at their expense.
But anyways, this story takes place in November
of that second grade year.
Just after Halloween.
We were sitting in math class, boring as ever.
When situations like this arise, which were
quite often during math, Kevin and I would
meet in the bathroom and trade baseball cards.
We had a system.
One of us would give the signal, and we would
stagger our bathroom requests as not to raise
suspicion from our teacher.
On this particular occasion, Kevin had gone
off to the bathroom first and I gave it a
good 5 minutes before raising my hand.
As I was waiting to be called on, our teacher,
Mr Davis, was interrupted by the sound of
the intercom, which was strange because they
usually only did announcements at the beginning
and end of the day.
"Attention all students and staff.
At this time we are conducting an internal
lockdown.
This is not a drill.
Please initiate lockdown at this time."
Our teacher was pretty calm with his response,
walking over to the door and locking it.
He told us all to line up along the back wall
and keep quiet as he crossed the room to pull
down the blinds.
I figured he had been though many lockdown
drills before and this probably wasn't anything
big.
We had a lock down at my old school once and
it turned out to be a parent who just forgot
to sign in.
We waited like that for about 5 minutes.
One kid asked Mr. Davis much longer it would
be, he got a hard Shh! from our teacher, signalling
that no talking would be tolerated.
It was about at that time when I remembered
that Kevin was still in the bathroom.
I debated in my head on whether I should bring
this to the teacher's attention, but was ultimately
too scared after seeing that other kid get
scolded for making a peep.
That might sound kind of ridiculous given
the circumstances, but keep in mind, I was
only 7 years old at the time and still very
intimidated by authority.
We waited in silence for a little while longer.
With each minute that passed, the situation
got more tense.
I started to feel anxiety.
Butterflies in my stomach.
That's when there was another announcement
on the intercom.
This... circus music started playing over
the intercom.
And then... after that...
There was, what sounded like laughter in the
background.
One of the girls in the class asked Mr. Davis
what was going on.
He told her to keep quiet, but his voice cracked
and he stuttered in saying so.
That may have actually been the scariest part
of the whole ordeal for me.
Being a kid, and seeing an adult... and on
top of that, someone who you're supposed to
feel safe with being visably shaken like that.
It was terrifying.
I guess I wasn't the only one who felt that
way.
I could hear sniffles coming from one of the
other kids, like they had been crying.
Abruptly, the music just stopped.
We were all sitting on the floor in a line
in the corner of the room.
I actually closed my eyes, as if that would
somehow help me.
But nothing could block out the breathing
that I heard blaring over the school intercom.
Until it stopped.
We sat in silence for a while longer.
Hearts racing.
Minds racing faster.
The silence was broken by a slam and a group
of screams!
The sound traveled from down the hall.
At this, I opened my eyes to see Mr. Davis
jump up and push the big wooden teacher's
desk from across the room in front of the
door.
I noticed tears streaming down his cheeks
as he did so.
I started to feel sick to my stomach as the
anxiety continued to build.
Footsteps approached from down the hallway.
They stopped near our door.
I could see a shadow on the wall.
Someone was standing out there.
I could tell by the shape that...
It was the shadow of a clown.
After a short pause it seemed the shadow had
disappeared and I started to feel a little
bit of relief that the clown had walked away.
There was a bang on the door and suddenly,
and standing at the door window was a terrifying
looking clown with bright white face paint,
a huge cartoony, toothy smile painted on his
face to contrast the cold evil looking smirk
on his actual lips.
He was somewhat overweight and wore a big
baggy clown suit.
The whole class screamed as he repeatedly
tried to open the door.
He went from trying to wiggle the doorknob
free to rearing back and trying to kick in
the wooden door, the class screaming each
time he did so.
It realistically didn't last that long before
he gave up and moved on, but it felt like
forever to me at the time.
That was the last we saw of the mysterious
lockdown clown.
But in all of the hysteria, I completely forgot
about Kevin.
The lockdown lasted for another 20 minutes
or so until each room was cleared.
They made the announcement over the intercom,
telling us the lockdown was over and teachers
could resume classes.
They didn't actually ever say what had happened,
probably not wanting to raise any panic.
A few minutes later, Kevin appeared at the
door and looked like an absolute wreck.
His hair was literally standing up on end,
he had dark circles around his eyes and tears
streaming down his face.
His entire body was shaking.
I'd never seen someone looking so disheveled.
Class was once again interrupted so that our
teacher could escort Kevin to the nurse.
He didn't come back to class after that.
And his parents ended up holding him out of
school for 3 FULL WEEKS to recover.
He came back just before Winter Break.
I asked him what had happened a couple times,
but he always just told me that he didn't
want to talk about it.
He ended up coming to school for the rest
of second semester before his family moved
away at the start of that summer.
He was just never quite the same after that.
We never got an official story on what had
happened, only a swirl of rumors that the
intruder had never actually been found.
I shudder to think about what would have happened
if Mr. Davis hadn't pushed the desk up along
the door...
Anyways, I remembered about this story all
these years later because...
I oftentimes cut through this park on the
way home from the bus station.
They had a carnival going on over the weekend.
It was was closed now, and it was about 2:00AM
as I cut through the fairground.
At one of the ticket booths, a light had been
left on, the only light in entirety of area
for that matter.
And that's when I saw a clown crash up against
the glass and stare at me with those wide
eyes.
It may have been just some teenagers, or YouTubers
pulling a prank.
But I ran.
As fast as I could.
And didn't stop until I was locked inside
of my room.
Because clowns terrify me now.
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total for this episode comes out to $27,
but if you like this video right now, I'll
waive that fee and give you everything you
just listened to absolutely free.
The creepy clown music was done by the talented
Robert Austin and this outro music you are
listening to right now was performed by Naoya
Sakamata.
I hope you enjoyed the October upload marathon
and what little time you have left...
this Halloween.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.